I'm nervous to sit up there and laugh I
don't know what if my butt feels weird
and he calls me out on it he's like you
have a weird but get off me you know
everyone be going to the malls of their
families during a holiday and you know I
always want to do that and I never had a
chance to I would go to malls all the
time with my grandmother and she's
Israeli and she's like why do you want
to sit on a man's left like that you
know beyond like some intimate level and
just like this is what I want is what I
really want and somebody can be like yes
it's gonna happen I'm gonna make it
happen for you sounds wonderful art it's
just pitter-pattering have a lot of
respect for you and the most aberration
so I just ask you anything or any
presence or within reason obviously a
boyfriend
oh maybe like 6 foot light eyes lots of
hair he doesn't you know religious on a
big thing for me I would really like a
black pug I you know I'm thinking that
I'm gonna need to get a toy stuff all
right pet shop up there with the toy
shop yeah I would love an Xbox one an
xbox woman the girlfriend doesn't want
to get it to me because apparently is
too violent for her to have in the house
but I would play it when she was
sleeping so she wouldn't know
the only thing is that that I don't know
if I can find something like that put
them in the sleigh and deliver them home
no you can't deliver him to me no Anna
if you can't get it to me I mean we've
got FedEx I'd like for just people to be
a little bit more like consciously aware
of being nice exactly that's the
Christmas spirit can I take a selfie
with you oh is that possible oh I do
selfies in fact powerful we have it now
[ __ ] they're at the North Pole
we call him Sophie oh no way yeah his
name was because he hang out with Alf on
the shelf well okay all right let's do
this